It concerns decisions
taken at the European Union level
to manage finances
of member countries
It aims to ensure economic stability and promote growth
To this end,
the EU establishes a budget that allows funding
to be done in areas such as research,
agriculture or education
And this budget is mainly fed by contributions
of the Member States
Then there is the policy
of cohesion
which aims to reduce the economic gaps between
European regions
It helps the regions
the least developed in
providing them with additional funds
So much for politics
European budget
If this video helped you,
share it
drop a like and subscribe!